Let's uh let's let's get into what you
just said about I'd rather have the
Chinese government than a journalist
with my information and who the real
enemies are because we got some we got
some uh updates we had the story from
Fox News Glenn Greenwald the NSA had
legal obligation to conceal Tucker
Carlson's identity from intercepted
Communications I love this I love the
story because it follows those steps
like you laid out right first they were
like Tucker's full of it nobody's spying
on them and they said well okay you know
maybe but not really we're at the point
now where it's well so okay fine but
it's not a big deal I mean he was trying
to talk to Putin so of course they were
they were spying on him they're just
spying on American journalists in
general right they unmasked Tucker
Carlson yep
no it's remarkable and you mean there I
think they're they're still probably
important details that we don't yet know
we might never know but just the story
as it's out now is remarkable and I
think it does represent a substantial
escalation in our March toward this
dystopian Health State because uh yes we
know they're look they're surveilling
our stuff yes we know it's you can you
should expect that they're looking at
especially if you're communicating with
you know Russian officials and so forth
but the unmasking and the leaking and
the political weaponization of that is a
remarkable step and it could gesture
toward what becomes the new Norm which
is uh you know just the logical
extension of the fact that our national
security state has become a political
weapon right and that's you know that's
the whole I mean this is this is war on
terror it's it's it's like the Soviet
Union right exactly and and it's it is
strange though that this is the thing
because
um you've had journalists like Megan
Kelly interview Putin and otherwise so
it's like well she was probably spot on
as well well sure she was
um but this idea that
this is how they're going to embarrass
Tucker
like I I'm jealous of of of of Tucker if
the most embarrassing thing about him is
that he was seeking an interview with
Putin and assuming like the NSA is
looking at everything we're doing you
know
um uh well there there are limits I
suppose right so um if if information
leaked that Tucker Carlson was going to
meet with Vladimir Putin right people
would start to make assumptions about
who may have been involved right perhaps
the leak would have been substantially
worse so I'll put it this way let's say
the NSA is spying on Tucker to an
extreme degree like they know that he
just went out and bought some flowers
and chocolates for his wife and they
know what he the note he submitted to
the store to you know he sent a note
saying please includes in the card when
you send the flowers to my wife I'm so
sorry we fought last night please let's
never fight again and then they're like
oh we got trouble at home we can make
him look like a bad husband this this
leak is going to be a great smear but
when Tucker then says the NSA is spying
on me right it puts them in a limited
position because now if they come out
and say here though here's Tucker
Carlson's web history Street everyone's
gonna be like whoa whoa the NSA is doing
all that right now it's kind of like hey
the NSA incidentally picked up one of
his emails right no but if they actually
were spying on them this preemptive move
from Tucker was brilliant it stopped
them from releasing the worst of the
worst if they actually had it yeah I
mean depending what the worst was and
you know they're in a position to do
that ultimately Google is in a position
to do that just you know almost as much
as the NSA itself and the question is
that's an existential risk to the
company if you know as bad as Google has
been if they release the contents of
people's gmails or G chats or something
for political purposes that I think is a
severe risk to the company just an
economic sense even in this environment
and so if they were to do that they'd
better make sure that it's a worthy
Target and the right time and so forth
and so
um so yeah I think the Tucker story is
is yet to maybe play out in full but
absolutely I think it was the right move
for him to go preemptive because the
story at the present moment I think
looks much worse for the NSA so they
were looking to embarrass him with an
interview with Putin which isn't even
embarrassed of why wouldn't a major
journalist of his stature be looking
trying to do an interview with Putin
because maybe the story was something
else there you go maybe the story was
Tucker Carlson you know uh sent a lewd
message to an intern or something
and they had Communications maybe and
Tucker's like that was a text message to
Thai son
but then when he says this the NSA is is
now named if it if the story was hackers
how did we get the info I must have been
hackers must have been you know a breach
if Tucker didn't say anything it could
have been anyone but he called it the
NSA specifically so it sounds like it
was the NSA and they were forced to hold
back I don't know that's true or not but
I this story is not even embarrassing
right why would someone go to Tucker and
say hey look they're gonna do this thing
unless either Tucker is clean as a
whistle and they're full of it and
they're desperate or they got put on the
spot had to back down
right I think there are a number of
possibilities so it's it's an
interesting story we're working on
incomplete information but in so far as
the story is the NSA is spying on
journalists and they're willing to leak
things for political purposes that's
absolutely I don't think that's a
controversial out State how deep is it
do they subpoena Google to send them
every voice because this is recording
right now waiting to hear its own name
the Google and the Amazon machine is
listening do they just have complete
access to all of this data at all times
basically I mean anything that isn't
encrypted
which is basically everything yeah yes
the stuff that's encrypted they have
stored on in some you know Warehouse in
the southwest
um and they're just waiting until they
have the computing power to get it right
even if it's 10 years from now they've
got a bunch of interesting stuff they're
just waiting for the computer power to
get it but
um
yeah this is my my warning to the
average person
these Amazon devices we've got one in
the room how does it know when its name
is said
so the way these devices work is that an
audio file of what you say is sent to a
company that then transcodes the audio
file into text which the computer can
then read and then ask questions and
things like that that means these
devices have to be on and listening all
the time it doesn't mean necessarily
they're sending everything you say off
to these companies but
but it might be the case they have in
the past in the past that's how you say
in the terms of service for a lot of
these services that everything you say
is sent to a company to be transcribed
and that means that your phones were
always listening right but I think it
would be absurd it was constantly
transmitting every word you said full
audio files I mean that would be a hefty
data transmission you'd probably notice
right so early on what a lot of the
phones did was they would make you say
the word three times to panic to get a
pattern from your voice so that when you
could say something as for these home
networks
you know what we got an I.T guy we
should probably track that and see if
we're if we're getting you know we'll
try we'll like shut off all the data
except for these devices and see what
they do when they're you know isolated
dude they're harvesting everything for
everything data is so cheap these days
Quantum Computing has shifted the game
and it could be compressing so it's hard
hard to track but uh the other thing
about Chuck Carlson too is you know when
he mentioned the sixth and you mentioned
this as well the federal involvement yep
the potential Federal involvement I
guess is there is there any evidence to
back up that claim other than informants
or potential informants
well I mean there's a tremendous
evidence and um
it depends how much time you want to
spend on this because I use organization
revolver.news we have two major pieces
on this topic the first piece with the
subject that was basically
um the inspiration for the monologue the
Tucker's monologue which uh became the
biggest story in the country and I went
on and I said my piece there as well
um so it depends in how much detail you
want to go just to give the highlights
for people listening who may not have
may not have heard this and are
interested I think one thing that
generally
um perks people's attention is just
something that nobody thought to remark
upon and that is that just
we don't have to go all the way back to
J Edgar Hoover to detail
um the malfeasance of the FBI and other
organizations for 1 6 you just need to
go back a couple months to this
so-called Michigan kidnapping plot right
the Michigan plot and in a nutshell what
this was was this was a plot to kidnap
the governor of Michigan who was very
Draconian on on coveted policies but
that plot also involved many people
don't know this it also involved a plot
to storm the Michigan State Capitol
the so-called Mastermind of this plot
was a member of a militia group called
three percenters which is one of the
three major militia groups imputed to 1
6. so you have the same plot one of the
same militia groups and you have of the
18 plotters we now know that at least
five were either undercover agents or
informants 5 out of 18 is a hell of a
ratio and just as a cherry on top
the head of the Detroit
FBI field office who is in charge of
this infiltration operation Michigan
just days after the plotter's so-called
plotters were arrested FBI director Ray
promoted him to the D.C field office
when he where he went on to oversee the
1-6 investigation now I'm not suggesting
that that logically means 1 6 means
anything I have my own argument about 1
6 that I can get into but for people who
have initial resistance just in terms of
their sense that we don't do that that's
not the kind of thing we do you don't
need to go back to J Edgar Hoover you
just need to go back a couple months
prior to the so-called storm on the
capital and you see one of the same
militia groups the same plot one of the
same FBI agents associated with both
events and a federal infiltration ratio
of 5 out of 18. and you're telling me
that you had this and you didn't and and
the explanation for the uniquely poor
Security on one six is simply that this
was an intelligence failure did you see
that video of the men wearing all black
blackout gear breaking into the capital
what's that all about yeah I mean it's
there's there's a lot of video that's
suspicious and even more suspicious
there's a lot of video that hasn't yet
been released
um but we uh that the facts are
trickling in we now know that the D.C
police had an undercover agent in the
morning of 1-6 and so first of all the
D.C police was sufficiently concerned to
put an informant on the ground in one
six and yet they had uniquely poor
security at the Capitol that seems
incongruent and furthermore it seems to
beggar belief that the D.C police would
have an informant on the ground and
actually an undercover agent on the
ground not an informant and the FBI
wouldn't have anyone so uh but that
isn't even the argument that we get to
in the piece it depends how interested
you are how interested you think your
audience is in in a real breakdown I
don't know okay so basically the
structure of the first piece is as false
it gives the Michigan kidnapping plot to
reinforce people's intuition but then
what it does is it looks at the charging
documents related to the people actually
indicted for a major 1-6 related crimes
specifically people who belong to the
major militia groups which was the uh
priority of the prosecution
and it notes there's something really
weird here you have the one of the
original prosecutors named Michael
Sherwin he said unabashedly we're going
at this with a shock and awe standard of
prosecution that is the most severe
standard imaginable to give you a
concrete sense of what that means
there's a guy called George tanios who
was at the Capitol he was in the melee
he had bear spray on him
his friend came up to him and wanted to
get the bear spray said is it time
should we should we spray some cops
he said no no not yet
for saying no no not yet
he's facing 60 years in prison that's
what that's what shock and awe means and
just incidentally the whole reason the
bear spray was a big deal is that after
basically revolver.news exposed that
officer sicknick was not bludgeoned to
death by a fire extinguisher they
shifted The Narrative to oh he was
killed by bear spray we did a very shift
at it again yeah we did a very detailed
comparative image analysis at revolver
Don news and said Not only was he not
killed by bear spray he wasn't even
sprayed by bear spray and so that was
the whole reason the bear spray was
relevant to begin with so his friend
comes up to him and says is it I I want
to get the bear spray he says no no not
yet he's facing 60 years thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time